[Laughter]
[Music]
they paved my road when I was seven or
eight years old I rode that school bus
that first day and I I came home and I
was the first time I'd ever looked at my
my own situation and it's like I'm poor
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
industrial hemp has played a key role
really in the founding of this country
the first American flags that were made
in this country were made of industrial
hemp and we had actually gotten our seed
in April the DEA didn't agree that we
had a right to plant the crop they've
said they were gonna arrest us for
breaking the law the one question that I
get asked the most is what the hell are
you gonna do is this stuff the grant
from Patagonia allowed the veterans to
build a machine to process their hemp by
hand there was no infrastructure they
couldn't do it any other way
thank you this is a extreme privilege
and a and an honor I would first like to
thank every man and woman that has put
on a uniform in defense of our fellow
citizens
from the simple hempseed and the means
to make the cordage that was converted
into the sails and ropes that brought
the first explorers to America and later
would feed the printing presses that
would organize our first militias and
ultimately helped us declare our
independence
[Music]
in 2014 with the help of some fellow
veterans we've planted hemp seeds on our
farm and much like those earlier
settlers we embarked on a journey into
uncharted waters
we chose to grow and create an American
flag on principle I suppose as we have
lost our connection with the land and
the people who fed us we've lost our
sense of community and more importantly
our sense of place the flag represents a
collective history and future of an
entire nation of people our people
so it shouldn't be made anywhere other
than here and you should most certainly
not be made cheaply in the end there is
more than just fiber that tears and
fades when you use cheap goods to hold
things together it is no secret that
America needs more farmers but we need
the tools to be successful an industrial
hemp is a cornerstone for financial and
resource stability on the family farm we
are just one small team with limited
resources and we took simple seeds and
we turned them into this flag that
represents the strength and ingenuity of
the American farmer
[Music]
I can only imagine what wonders we will
see when every American farmer has the
opportunity to grow this amazing crop
thank you
[Music]
[Music]